[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hey.
It's Stephanie Wong,
and welcome back to
"What's New in
Networking," where we
cover what's new in networking.
Today, I'm covering the updates
for Core Infrastructure.
There's a lot to catch up
on, so let's get into it.
Right off the bat, we have
some exciting Cloud region
announcements.
We've launched new Cloud
regions in Delhi, India;
Melbourne, Australia;
and Warsaw, Poland.
Delhi and Melbourne
are the second regions
within those markets, enabling
in-country disaster recovery
for mission-critical
applications.
Meanwhile, Warsaw is the
first region in Poland
and the seventh in Europe.
Designed for high
availability, regions
open with three
availability zones
to protect against
service disruptions
and offer a portfolio
of our key products,
including Compute Engine,
Kubernetes Engine, Cloud
Storage, Cloud
Spanner, and BigQuery.
If you deploy workloads
in those regions,
you'll benefit from lower
latency and high availability
for your users.
We're also expanding our
Interconnect locations,
including Phoenix, Arizona;
Minneapolis, Minnesota;
Copenhagen, Denmark;
and Warsaw, Poland,
adding to over 110 locations.
Dedicated Interconnect provides
direct physical connection
between your on-premises
network and Google's network.
Dedicated Interconnect
enables you
to transfer large amounts of
data between networks, which
can be more cost-effective than
purchasing additional bandwidth
over the public internet.
With additional
locations, we're making
it more accessible for you to
get direct physical connection
from your own network
to Google's, including
up to 100 gigabits
per second circuit.
Next up, Cloud
Router's new features.
Cloud Router is our
fully-managed service that uses
Border Gateway Protocol--
BGP-- to advertise
IP address ranges.
Like you saw in
the last section,
it's used to setup Dedicated
Interconnect, as well
as high-availability VPN,
and serves as a control
plane for Cloud NAT.
You can now disable or enable
a BGP session on Cloud Router
at a per-peer level.
Previously, you were not able to
enable or disable specific BGP
sessions on Cloud Router.
You can now do so by issuing a
command through the API, CLI,
gcloud, or the Google Cloud
UI without terminating the BGP
session.
Say you've setup
Cloud Router, but you
want to change the
router configuration when
migrating to a
different BGP peer
or performing
maintenance on a peer.
You can disable the
session per-peer safely
with a quick command,
update the settings,
and enable the session.
This gives you the flexibility
to make configuration changes
per-peer without resetting
the BGP session or disabling
and re-enabling the interconnect
or VPN link it sits on.
Now let's talk about
the Keepalive timer.
The Cloud Router and
your on-premise router
maintain communication
by using timer settings.
The Keepalive timer is the
interval between periodic BGP
heartbeat messages exchanged
between a Cloud Router
and the on-premises router,
and indicates whether a router
is reachable to its BGP peer.
You can now modify the
Keepalive timer on Cloud Router.
Previously, it was static, with
a default value of 20 seconds.
But now you can change it
to a value between 20 and 60
seconds.
This way, you can
set a higher value
on the Google Cloud side in case
you have a longer hold timer
before a failure is triggered.
Once the hold timer is hit,
the BGP session is torn down.
One thing to note is we
recommend setting the Keepalive
timers to the same value
on your on-premises router
and the Cloud Router.
Together, these
features provide you
with flexibility in
managing and troubleshooting
BGP sessions with Cloud Router.
Serverless VPC access allows you
to create VPC connectors that
connect serverless services,
like App Engine, Cloud
Run, and Cloud Functions,
to a VPC network.
When you create a connector
in your Google Cloud project,
you attach it to a specific
VPC network and region.
You can then configure
your serverless services
to use the connector for
outbound network traffic,
like accessing Compute
Engine instances
and any other resources
with an internal IP address.
While serverless VPC
access automatically
provisions throughput
for a connector
in 100 megabits per
second increments,
based on the amount of
traffic sent through,
you could still face
throughput limits
if the connector was deployed
using a smaller machine type.
With this update, you can
select larger instances
to support more throughput
and set new scaling settings.
You can set the
connector machine
type and the min and max number
of instances it can scale to.
If traffic requires
it, the connector
can scale up to the
max number configured.
With the update,
you can achieve up
to 16 gigabits per
second of throughput
by specifying a
larger machine type.
That's it for networking
updates for Core Infrastructure.
Check out the links
to learn more,
and stay tuned for
our next episode
of "What's New in Networking."
[MUSIC PLAYING]